[موسيقى]
اقول لك على حاجه
ما عرفش كيف الناس بتدافع عنك
حتى وانت كيف الميتين
[موسيقى]
مرحبا في اجتماعي تجسد لوجينا شخصيه امراه
يموت زوجها في مسلسل لتتخلى عن الثوب
النساء وترتدي ثوب الرجال من اجل الكفاح
للكسر الحلال لقمه العيش حيث تتعرض للعديد
من مشاكل والازمات بدايه من دخولها فستان
ابيض على اياد نصار اللي يلعب دور زوجها
في العمل وحملها طفل على يديها والدخول في
سوى العزاء وارتداء ثوب الرجال مرورا
بمعاناتها للعيش بالحلال والكفاح قصه ليست
جديده وشخصيه تكررت عده مرات في الدراما
فام الجديد هذه المره القصه مختلفه تماما
يعني احنا عمرنا ما شفنا قصه ست ارتدت زي
راجل وبقت راجل وبتعمل اعمال الرجال يعني
كنا متخيلين في نموذج واحد في المجتمع
بهذا الشكل اكتشفنا انه في اكثر من نموذج
في المجتمع لستات اشتغلت في حاجات كتيره
قوي ولكن مهنه تناسب الرجل وليس المراه
فعشان كده انا بشوف ان ده حاجه مختلفه في
المسلسل دم من الافكار والمشاريع اللي
كانت عندي بقالها كتير جوايا
وبالتالي في يوم كده يعني
قال يعني زي هاجس واضح ان انا حابب قوي
اعمل الشخصيه دي والتركيبه دي والشكل
العام للمشروع ده
والكلام ده كان في رمضان اللي فات حقيقه
يعني قبل انتهاء الشهر الكريم واتكلمت
معاها روجينا واخذنا قرار ان شاء الله ان
احنا يبقى ده مشروعنا القادم
للمرقه في صوره عمل درامي وهو من تاليف
ناصر عبد الرحمن واخراج رؤوف عبد العزيز
في ثاني تعاون ما بينهم مع روجينا بعد
مسلسل الانحراف اللي تصدر ترند جوجل اكثر
من مره في رمضان المال عمل اجتماعي
الصعيدي عن المراه الصعيديه اللي هي
تكرمها الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي في في
الايام الاخيره هي قصه حقيقيه اتمنى بس ان
هي تلمس الناس وهما كده كده عارفين الحاج
بصيص وعارفين قصتها يعني
فهيتعاطفوا جدا معاها يا رب يخشوا في قصه
قوي هو طبعا حاجات متجانسه في بعض ليه
علاقه بكذا مشكله
وكذا لاين لمشاكل كثير بتحصل لحد دلوقتي
يعني في الصعيد وبعدين انا ما اقدرش اقول
من رايي في ورق الاستاذ يعني ده يعني راي
لا يذكر طبعا بالنسبه لتاريخه بس بس ده
حقيقي هو بيقدم حاجات مختلفه ومشاكل
لجيل دلوقتي وجي كده وهيحصل